Atlanta's hartsfield-jackson is the
busiest airport in the world over 2,500
planes land and take off every day with
more than 250,000 passengers
jetting to 225 destinations in 50
countries all around the globe
Delta Airlines is responsible for 75% of
that air traffic but the airlines entire
operation extends far beyond its
headquarters in Atlanta with over 5,000
flights a day all around the world and
managing it all is a logistical
nightmare this room is Mission Control
for the airline it's a place that few of
us get to see as passengers but which
has a huge impact on our journeys
there's data coming in here on
everything from the weather to our
flight paths to air traffic control to
passenger issues it's all monitored for
every plane anywhere in the world it
looks like a NASA facility and that's
because there are around 300 specialists
here dealing with that incessant flow of
information that streams in 24/7 it is
key not only to know where each and
every airplane is but it's also key to
know where each and every customer is on
those airplanes giant screens at the
front display the most critical
information and each desk has what looks
like the world's most impenetrable
spreadsheets so as you look around this
vast office you'll see that each and
every dispatcher each and every entity
has their own flight following tool set
specifically to their area of the world
with which they're working we add into
that all the complexity of the ATC
environment in the FAA environment what
he means is that they're sharing data
and updates with air traffic control
managers at airports all over so you can
kind of see how managers here are a sort
of benign Big Brother maintenance is
another key function getting a spare
part to a stranded flight can make the
difference between a cancellation or not
of course delays do happen one in ten
flights actually won't take off on time
and when things do go wrong because a
storm rolled in or someone just forgot
to fuel the jet staff here start work
trying to divert the flight to find new
crew or to get passengers onto a
different aircraft it's a stressful job
and it may be a thankless task because
if it all runs smoothly passengers will
never know this room exists